بعد 39 عامًا من
هذه الليلة، تصر القوات الروسية على أنها
تستعيد السيطرة على مجموعة ممن
يسمونهم بالمخربين الذين يتسللون إلى هذه
الحدود المورقة.
هذه الصور التي يُزعم أنها تظهر
جنديًا روسيًا يعتقل ثلاثة منهم،
تم بثها على وسائل الإعلام الرسمية
مع الروس المناهضين للكرملين الذين
يستولون الآن على المنطقة.  قال: "القتال في الوطن،
هذه هي الطريقة التي نعمل بها"، وسط
غارة جريئة مدرعة عبر الحدود الأوكرانية
إلى روسيا نفسها.
لا تستطيع "سي إن إن" التحقق بشكل مستقل من أي من
الصور، ولكن تم رصد هذا العمود بأكمله من
المركبات وهو يعبر
الحدود، وتصر القوات الأوكرانية على أنهم
ليسوا هم، ولكن  الجماعات الروسية المنفية التي
تقاتل ضد الكرملين
نحن روس مثلكم تمامًا نريد
لأطفالنا أن يكبروا في سلام وأن يكونوا
أحرارًا حتى يتمكنوا من السفر للدراسة ويكونوا
سعداء ولكن هذا غير ممكن في
روسيا بوتين وقد
فاجأت الغارة حرس الحدود الروس
بذلك  حاول أحدهم أن يكون
بطلاً، كما يقول الراوي وسط
جوازات السفر المتناثرة، وصورة
فلاديمير بوتين المطلة على المذبحة
أسفل
الحدود مفتوحة الآن، ويقول أحد
المقاتلين الذي
سيلجأ بوتين إليه قريبًا هوني، ويقول
الآخر، وبعبارة أخرى، يموت
على شاشة التلفزيون الذي يسيطر عليه الكرملين
وقف مقدمو العروض مثل التماثيل أثناء
إعادة عرض أحداث اليوم
[موسيقى]
ودمرتهم
على مقاطع فيديو من السكان المحليين المذهولين الذين شهدوا
القتال.
وصف الكرملين الهجوم بأنه
تحويل، ولكن هناك بالفعل
انتقادات حادة من المتشددين الروس
للسماح بحدوث هذا في
هذه المنطقة الروسية المجاورة مباشرة
أوكرانيا ليست غريبة على الهجمات عبر الحدود
ولكن التوغلات المسلحة مثل هذه
نادرة، وقد
تغير المزاج هنا وفقًا للمسؤولين الروس المحليين
مع وصول حافلات فارغة لإجلاء
السكان بينما يغادر أولئك الذين يستطيعون
المغادرة بأنفسهم،
فهم نائب وزير الدفاع وليس
وزير العلوم.  بل توفي بعد أن شعر
بمرض أه على متن طائرة يوم السبت، وذلك
وفقًا لوزارة العلوم
والتعليم العالي، وكان منتقد بوتين
جزءًا من وفد روسي عائد
من رحلة عمل إلى كوبا وقامت
الطائرة بهبوط اضطراري في
جنوب روسيا حيث كان الأطباء
حاولت علاجه دون جدوى،
سبب الوفاة غير معروف ولكن من
المقرر تشريح الجثة يوم الأربعاء. سي إن إن
سلمى عبد العزيز تتابع هذه
التطورات وتنضم إلينا الآن مع
سلمى الأخيرة تخبرنا بما تعرفه وتفاجأت أيضًا بأنه
سيكون هناك أي مجال
للشك  بالنسبة لأحد منتقدي الكرملين
داخل الحكومة في روسيا،
طوال هذا الصراع، كانت هناك
لحظات سمعنا منها،
وسأعطيكم مثال
شركات الطاقة المملوكة للدولة أه حيث شركة Luke Oil
هي تلك التي أذكرها
هنا انتقد الصراع في
أوكرانيا علنًا، كانت هناك لحظات
بالطبع خاصة في بداية
هذا الصراع حيث كانت هناك
أصوات تنحدر ولكن نتيجة ذلك
كانت سلسلة من الوفيات الغامضة وهذه
الوفاة الأخيرة هي بيتر كوسترانكو،
وهو أحد كبار القادة الروس  النائب هو
نائب وزير العلوم
والتعليم العالي ما فهمناه حصل
وهذا بحسب
صفحة معلومات موقع الوزارات أه هو أنه
كان عائدا من رحلة عمل في
كوبا أصيب بمرض على متن الطائرة الطائرة
هبطت في جنوب روسيا صحيح
تم علاجه بالقرب من الحدود مع جورجيا،
ووفقًا لموقع الوزارة على الإنترنت، فقد
توفي الآن، وقد أشار أفراد عائلته إلى
أنه من المحتمل أن
يكون مرضًا في القلب، ولكن
يتم التعامل مع هذا الأمر على أنه مريب
لأنه كان معروفًا أنه انتقد
الرئيس.  بوتين مؤخرًا
لصحفي بارز جدًا رومان سوبر الذي
قال إنه تحدث معه قبل أيام فقط من
رحلة العمل هذه إلى كوبا، قال إنه
في تلك المكالمة الهاتفية أعرب هذا
المشرع عن مخاوف جدية
بشأن سلامته وقال إنه كان
خائفًا على حياته  قال إنه كان
في الأساس رهينة لدى الكرملين، وتم
أخذ جواز سفره،
ولم يكن لديه سيطرة على تحركاته، وقال إنه
كان حزينًا ومكتئبًا،
وكان يتناول المهدئات ومضادات
الاكتئاب،
لذا أرسم صورة مقلقة للغاية هنا
أريد سحبها  يظهر لك هذا الرسم البياني ما يقرب
من عشرة
مسؤولين ورجال أعمال مختلفين منذ
بداية العام الماضي، وذلك في
وقت قريب من بداية غزو
أوكرانيا الذين ماتوا جميعًا أو سقطوا، كما
تعلم، لقوا حتفهم في عمليات
انتحار واضحة أريد أن  أحضر لك حالة
أحدهم الذي
توفي في سبتمبر بعد سقوطه
من نافذة المستشفى وكان
رئيسًا لإحدى شركات الطاقة هذه
وقد أعرب عن
انتقادات معارضة لحرب الرئيس بوتين
في أوكرانيا مرة أخرى
روسيا لا تدعي  المسؤولية
لن تعلن المسؤولية ولكن هذا
يزيد من مناخ الخوف الذي
تشعر فيه بوجود عواقب إذا
تحدثت علنًا